ariel sharon qui a été réélu largement
hier chef de son parti qui s'est engagé
à venger ses compatriotes assassinés à
mombasa au kenya les experts israéliens
sont à pied d'oeuvre sur le site même de
l'hôtel où a eu lieu l'explosion les
autorités à montbazens multiplié les
arrestations mais il faut rester très
prudent les douze personnes détenues ne
sont pas nécessairement impliquées dans
ces actes terroristes des touristes sont
d'ailleurs sur le point d'être relâché
le point de l'enquète avec sur place nos
envoyés spéciaux
dorothée olliéric edouard perrin ils
sont venus par dizaines des villages
voisins pour voir le paradis détruit
l'hôtel paradise qui accueillait depuis
des années une majorité de touristes
israéliens est figé dans ses cendres de
toute ma vie je n'ai jamais entendu une
explosion pareil à la france vous ne
pouvez vraiment pas imaginer le bruit
cela maintenant les gens ont vraiment
peur certains des employés sont restés
chez eux
d'autres ont même choisi les champs
juillet les stats et les kenyans sont
tenus à l'écart pour laisser place aux
enquêteurs israéliens alors qu'une
douzaine de suspects a été arrêté dans
la région
ici c'est un travail de fourmi chaque
débris du véhicule des kamikazes et
ramasser pour être examiné dans
l'après-midi les lieux du crime ont
pourtant été envahi et les probables 1
10 restant largement foulé aux pieds
pour le président kenyan son escorte et
sa suite l'important c'est de délivrer
un message fort c'est que nous allons
enquêter pour savoir qui sont les
conflits ceux qui ont permis aux
terroristes de commettre cet attentat
restent les conséquences inévitables sur
le tourisme on a dépensé beaucoup
d'argent et le temps pour moi l'image du
kenya tout ça est réduit à néant et on
va tout faire pour que la confiance
revienne financement bancaire à deux
kilomètres du paradise le club
seine-saint-denis si anglais allemands
hollandais poursuivre leurs vacances
comme si de rien n'était ou presque
c'est triste c'est vraiment très rare
mais ça ne nous touche pas vraiment ça
ne nous concerne pas directement
c'est la quatrième fois que je viens ici
et il en faudrait plus pour me frayer
je ne céderai pas
cet après midi pourtant la place de
kitambala était déserte
pour les touristes il n'est pas question
de s'aventurer trop loin des hôtels la
frontière avec la somalie est proche et
certains quartiers de mon bafa sont
réputés pour être infiltré par des
activistes du réseau al qaïda